The last barrier algorithm I'm going to describe
to you is what is called a Dissemination
Barrier. And it works by information diffusion in
an ordered manner among the set of participating
processes. And, what you will see is that
it is not pairwise communication as you saw
in the tree barriers and the NCS barrier
or the tournament barrier. But it is through
information diffusion. The other nice thing about
this particular barrier the dissemination barrier, is that
it is since it is based on ordered
communication among participating nodes. It's all like a,
a well-orchestrated gossip protocol. And therefore, N
need not be a power of 2. And
you will see why this condition need not
be satisfied as I start describing the algorithm
to you. So what's going to happen is that,
there's going to be information diffusion that's going to happen
among these processors in several different routes. And
in each round what's going to happen is that
a processor is going to send a message to
another ordained processor. And the particular processor that
it's going to choose to send it is dependent
on the round which we're in. So, the idea
is that processor Pi will send a message to
processor Pi plus 2 to the k mod N. This
is the peer to which Pi is going to send
a message to. And of course you know an example
is always more illustrative. So since we have five
processors here, we can then figure what's going to happen in
every round. And Round 0 k is going to be zero.
So what's going to happen, is that since k is zero,
Round 0, P0 is going to be sending a message to Pi plus 2k, k being zero,
is going to send it to P1. So, P0 sends a message to P1. Similarly P1 sends a
message to P2, P2 sends to P2 to P3 and P3 to P4. And the arrangement is
that this is cyclically arranged. That if before
the neighbor for him is going to be in the
cyclic order whoever is the next neighbor. So, in this
case since there is mod function that we using before is
going to be sending Its message to processor P5 mod. N,
N being, N, N being 5, it will be sending the
message to P0. So this is Round 0 of the
communication. So the key thing that I want you to get
is that in every round, we're going to see more rounds
in a minute in every round a processor is sending a
message to an ordained processor based on their own number.
But depending on their own numbers, their own number zero,
P0 sending to P1 and so on and so forth.
And that is what's going on. So this completes one round
of gossip. And what you, what you want to see
it that. All of these communications that I'm showing you
are parallel communications. They're not waiting on each other. So
P1, whenever it's ready to arrive at a barrier it's going to
tell the next gay, P2 is going to tell the next
guy when hes ready and so on. Now how will these
guys know that Round 0 is done well, if you take
any particular process here let's say P2, as soon as it
gets a message from P1 and it has sent a message
to P3. It knows that Round 0 has done so far
is as P2 is concerned, it can progress to the next
level, or next round of the dissemination. So, each of these
processes are independently making a decision that
the round is over based on two
things. One is, they have sent a message to the peer and they want
to receive the message from the ordain neighbor that they're supposed to get it
from. At the end of that, they can move on to the next round.